we make do we figure it out and I feel
like I've kind of figured out what works
for us on Sunday Kristin Cavallari and
Jay Cutler announced their split after
10 years and three kids together now a
source tells ET the two have been having
issues as a couple for a while but have
tried to work on their relationship
quote it's been hard for them as their
roles in the relationship have switched
tremendously in the beginning J was the
one working and gone a lot the football
and Kristin was at home with the kids
our source added that now the tables
have turned
Jay retired and he's home with the kids
and it's Kristin who's busy with her
jewelry line on Common James and other
ventures the couple just couldn't seem
to get back on the same page and knew it
was best for them to end things before
it got worse the reality star has been
pretty open about the changes in their
roles
ever since Jay retired from the NFL
following the 2017 season he is 35 he's
only ever known football he doesn't
really know what he wants to do but he's
35 he's gonna figure something out he'll
do something and I don't want to badger
him and push him and push N I'm working
and he's able to be home in court
documents obtained by et Christian cites
marital misconduct and irreconcilable
differences as the reason for the split
in the docs kristin claims that Jay is
guilty of such inappropriate marital
conduct as renders further cohabitation
on safe and improper as for their kids
seven-year-old Camden five year old
Jackson and 4 year-old sailor Kristen is
requesting primary physical custody with
visitation rights for Jay while he is
asking for joint custody and equitable
distribution of the marital assets
Kristen and Jay announced their plans to
divorce in a joint statement on
Instagram Sunday writing in part we have
nothing but love and respect for one
another and are deeply grateful for the
years shared memories made and the
children we are so proud of my kids my
family they're my number one priority
they always will be the reality star
says she and Jay
grown apart and asked for privacy as
they navigate this difficult time the
pair tied the knot in 2013 in Nashville
after dating on and off for years and
they've been open about their problems
on her reality show very Cavallari when
you were playing football like literally
I had to give up my whole life and I had
to just live your life and I never gave
you a hard time about it like it just
was what it was and I was at every game
and I supported you and I did everything
that I was supposed to do as a wife and
I feel like since I've gotten really
busy
I just haven't I don't feel that same
support from you and Kristin admitted
their marriage was far from
picture-perfect from the outside like
things are so perfect and things are so
great but actually like they're not and
that's so when et spoke to Kristen in
2018 she explained how the show affected
their marriage before we start shooting
season 1 we were very adamant about like
okay this is what we're willing to put
out there this is what we're not and we
just always talked about it so that
we're both really comfortable I think
too for me like I know this world I've
done it for so many years this is all
very new for him so I just always want
to make sure he is comfortable and he's
cool with everything that's happening